good evening everyone and welcome to
this evening's meeting of the
northwestern area planning committee
held today's 15th of june
my name is councillor maddie thompson
i'm the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through we're streaming
the meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone and speak clearly
sorry i've been distracted by messages
referencing a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers
please keep your contributions as clear
and concise as possible and ensure your
microphones remain off when not speaking
as this is important for the live
streaming to be heard clearly
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
not falling down the steps and
the fire escape being here if we needed
members can i draw your attention to the
members update which has information on
both items five and six both planning
applications right apologies for absence
please mr speaks
apologies i received from councillor
darren and councillor
thank you very much
right item three is the minute uh
members it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held
on
the last meeting i've got 30th of march
i'm sure that's wrong found on pages 7
to 12 were approved as a true and
accurate record may i take them as read
i haven't quite got there yet i so
propose could i have a second to please
okay are there any matters of accuracy
that any member wants to bring up
okay can i agree those by sent please
thank you very much
item four is declarations of interest i
have to read this i'm afraid to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda how in regard to paragraph
six to eight inclusive for code of
conduct for members members are reminded
they're also required to disclose any
such interests as soon as they become
aware should they need a rise to the
meeting
council fleming
thank you chairman a non-pecuniary as a
member of essex county council who are
statutory consultants thank you thank
you
anybody else no other takers
therefore we move on to our planning
applications the first one
is
22-0-4-3-9
land rear of hill barn
there is a members update as i said
we do have someone to speak now as both
of these applications apply to the same
site
the agent mr woods has opted to speak
once for them both but before that we'll
have the presentation please
application seeks panic mission for the
conversion of
existing
equestrian storage buildings to a live
work unit
the proposed the proposal would include
the
provisional provision of a free bedroom
dwelling and an area labeled as a
flexible office space
this application follows a previously
approved application 21-0-936-4
at this committee on the first december
2021
for the conversion of the barnes to
offices
an application 19012164
for the conversion of the building to a
dwelling with extensions
was also refused in april 2019 and the
appeal was dismissed in april 2020
this is the location plan for the
application as you can see the property
is located on the east side of rectory
lane and is located outside the
settlement boundary of wooden watermark
within the countryside
this is the existing site plan for the
application
this is the proposed site plan
which includes the converted barns and
outbuilding the parking area proposed to
the front of the buildings was approved
under previous application for offices
21-0
9364
these are existing barn elevations
these are the proposed barn elevations
this is the existing floor plan
this is the proposed floor plan the
proposed office space would amount to
130 square meters
of floor space and the proposed
residential dwelling would be
approximately 276 square meters
or which amounts to double the floor
space of the proposed office area
these are the floor plans approved and
the previous application which shows
that the whole floor area would be
offices
oh sorry
these are existing outbuilding
elevations and floor plans
these are the post outbuilding
elevations and floor plans which would
become a cycle store and storage area as
part of the proposed conversion
these are photos of the external
appearance of the existing barn
these are the photographs of the barn
from the front
front of the site
these are the photographs of the
existing out building in its very rural
context
this is a photograph of the existing
access drive
in line with the assessment carried out
within the committee report given the
fact that the level of residential
accommodation is more significant than
the level of employment land proposed is
considered that the proposal would be
tantamount to a new dwelling in the
countryside and would not constitute a
live work unit although the council's
policies support the principle of the
use of rural buildings for employment
generating purposes
subject to a number of specific criteria
there is
nothing within the adopted policies that
offer similar support for market housing
therefore the proposed running would not
be acceptable in principle as it would
be remote and disconnected from local
services and facilities by reason of its
location and would lead to domestication
of the site which would erode the
character and beauty of the countryside
which has not been adequate adequately
mitigated or justified as such the
application is therefore recommended for
refusal thank you chairman thank you
mr woods please come forward pick a
chair
we're just going to get the timer up so
make yourself comfortable
i know you know the rules but i'll say
it anyway for the benefit of people at
home you have two minutes precisely from
when you start to speak and i do mean
precisely
thank you
when you're ready thank you very much
good evening to members
the two applications before you seek
alternative residential use on the site
following on from the extent commercial
approval late last year
and which are sought to provide the
applicant with greater flexibility over
the future long-term use of the site to
best meet their needs
the principle of such alternative
developments on the site should be
supported and given the lawful full-back
position out-of-date nature of the local
plan
the support for such development
in national planning policy and when
applying the mppf's tilted balance
in the applicant's view the high quality
nature of these proposals
will enhance the site
allow inward investment and provide much
needed local housing through
effective conversion
which should be endorsed
it is also considered that the likely
intensity of these developments would
ultimately be less than that already
approved providing further net gain
it is noted that the two schemes designs
are similar to that already approved on
the site so visually there would be
little difference between them the
benefits of providing much needed new
housing in this form should also attract
significant weight in itself
the application was formally consulted
on with all statutory consultees
confirming that they have no objection
to the proposals with officers also
confirming the acceptability of the
proposals in all other planning related
respects
it is also important to highlight that
wooden and hazely parish council have
concluded that such residential
proposals would not provide
a negative impact on the current context
which adds further weight in support of
these proposals
the two applications have also generated
public support set out within the
offices committee report
these proposals were high quality and
would make effective reuse of the said
building to deliver much-needed housing
thank you
okay members
you'd like to go first i actually caught
kelsey plumbing first so
and then council morgan then councillor
please i think
thank you tim um
it says here that wood and mortimer
and hazely parish council haven't
commented
um but the speaker referred to
them being in support could the officers
just clarify thank you
sorry i'm actually just looking at the
camera i think you'll find the update
they uh in the update they have
commented on the second application
in support
yeah
does that help
have you looked at the members update
thank you chair yeah i did have a look
this afternoon i couldn't see it maybe i
missed it um
can i also just um ask the officers
if i'm remembering it correctly
when this came before us for offices
there was a tenant at the time but i
remember that correctly if any of the
committee can
think that far back
no um that they had a tenant to take the
offices is my memory of it i just was
wondering whether i'll help
but that doesn't mean there isn't
another one sorry mr d chairman um
but yeah we don't have that information
i can't confirm that um either way i
wouldn't think it's material
consideration in termination of either
of these applications
thank you
mr councilman
thank you chair um
so we've got two applications for the
same site would i be right perhaps
would it be illogical to sort of allow
one and not the other
that would depends to this
chairman um
um
my advice would be the plan system
doesn't work like that um it's not a
case of just you should if you've got
two options you should be able to choose
one or the other you know each
application needs to be assessed on its
own merits each application needs to be
compared against the policies if one of
the applications is except the council
politicians one of the others isn't one
should be approved and one should be
refused if both are in accordance with
policies then both should be approved
and if both are not in the country
policies then both should be refused
thank you chairman
right so so thank you thanks for that so
if we're minded to
to to uh we basically got two decisions
here one is to whether it's to do it or
not the other is to which one of the two
we want what's should we want to pass
but is that really where we are
chairman what says yeah these
applications are both been presented
separately while the
agent spoke about them together they are
being presented separately the first up
to me is simply that a live work
dwelling a little more complex i suppose
argue that it's a lift work dwelling and
second application relates solely to a
dwelling um
the question is to ignore the fact there
is a second application at the moment
discuss the first application obviously
the determination of the first one
perversity will become a teal
consideration and determination of the
next application but at the moment i'd
have advising members to
look at um this application
completely on its own irrespective of
the second one and i'll provide a verbal
update after terminating this
application thank you chairman yes sorry
i should perhaps i should have clarified
mr woods opted to speak for both at once
he didn't have to he could have chosen
to speak twice um but we're dealing with
the items completely separately
sorry just
is the what is the barn is the barn in
use at the moment
[ __ ] having the lawful use to our
understanding is as an equestrian use uh
storage it could be well it's not nasty
it looks derelict to me
it doesn't look in the greatest
condition but um i wouldn't say that it
couldn't have repair maintenance or
um got certainly i think right if i come
right back on this point i think that's
there's a certain point that
if
building is a state that members think
that it can't be it's not in a condition
really to be able to be used or repaired
that would why even favour of not
supporting the development that isn't
part of what the lpa are putting forward
the lpa taking out face value there is a
building there that with certain level
of repair maintenance could function and
that is the stance that the lpa is
paying for but obviously as members are
aware the fact if you consider about a
building is in such bad condition that
it can't function that would weigh in
favor of doing something that retains
that structure not way
so it would way in favor of not
supporting the attention of the
structure rather than way in favor of
allowing additional development that
does retain it if that makes sense
uh yes it just it just strikes me that
in terms of visual immunity i mean
you're sort of replacing something that
looks pretty hideous with something that
might be a lot better but it's just a
little bit thank you thank you
please
be on clarity what i would say is that
you know all buildings all developments
have a lifespan there's a natural
point and this isn't this about this
application this is just generally an
advisement
regulator there is a all development has
a natural lifespan and eventually
structures will come to appear a state
where they will start to uh
look unacceptable in the character area
um the council does have powers to um
resolve that if it's considered to be so
bad um so significant to the character
the area
but obviously as always i advise is that
just because a building as is may call
some harm now at the moment you've got
to remember that any planning permission
you grant
will
um remain if got built have a whole new
life lifetime will cause a level of harm
in the future for a lot longer than just
this moment of maybe slightly
degradation etcetera and also what i'll
always say is
i'll be very wary of having a building
is slightly tight untidy or has some
detrimental impact on the character area
as a reason to allow a new development
especially around agricultural buildings
because i would say that you're probably
quite likely to encourage
applications coming forth it's very
slightly
um untidy buildings and if that is a
material situation the committee starts
giving significant weight too regularly
there'll be no way of the authority
stopping that you will be setting a very
dangerous precedent of using that as a
material consideration that will be able
to be used across the district it might
start about five year land supply
position
being a bit hanging cheap but it would
not support the delivery of hounds in
acceptable occupation so irrespective of
this application that's just a bit of
advice generally about uh looking at
that point of principle until
consideration thanks thanks i mean it
would after all need an awful lot of
work for any use for anything except
sticking hay bales in that you don't
much care about unless you've got a lot
of tarpaulins
i think councilman morley would be able
to advise us on that but i won't go
don't worry i think i had counselor keys
next
um if i go back to the pictures my it's
not as good was it did i see eight
offices it was possible
in the previous time
yeah
where did our sales so there was eight
parking spaces or nine parking spaces
was it them
we go back further
yeah that's it
vehicle parking boats
right
okay
oh you probably wouldn't get that if we
had a three bedroom bell in there we
wouldn't need so many cars and can we go
back to the pictures of the barns but i
just want to clarify something
counselor more um
morgan
that's it yeah right
right so then buildings there are the
ones that have got application for
offices
and where would the extension go
is it towards us now where that door is
open is that where the new bit is added
that bit there where it says
open plan offices so that says
bit there
open plan offices
yeah
so
is it i thought it said the footprint
was bigger
so it's exactly the same exactly the
same footprint right no alterations at
all
right for a free bedroom first
night like things from
councilwoman
thank you madam chairman yeah i i
actually spoke up in favor of this um at
the last meeting
but i think
i'm not so fussed about it being a live
work unit that doesn't bother me so much
as long as it stays with work because i
think the harm would probably be less
because there'd be less cars
so there'd be less public there'd be
less movements
so from that point of view i've got no
problem
but i think
what i'd like to see is whether we i
think my concerns are is if we approve
the live work dwelling is there any way
that we can protect the work part so it
can't just then be removed
sorry mr um dear chairman um
i think look
i think to answer cancer white's
question it's always two parts one is
the principle of it which is yes you can
um otherwise you know there wouldn't be
such a thing as live work in the
planning system
the second part is whether or not how it
ties into this relationship and this
application and as the office's report
explains taking into account the volume
of
the residential accommodation compared
to the volume of office space and
or space and how that would interact
there are concerns about the ability for
that to be classed as a live work unit
and with his ability to condition that
requirement though um just
how no different to
a good condition an outbuilding has to
remain ancillary or anything like that
so there are abilities to
require that in perpetuity but
there's just obviously if there was
concerns about the ability to
in the long term to retain that then we
may have to quit retaining that
condition so it might fall up it could
in theory fall away and that's what the
officers report talks about this but in
principle yes it can
sorry ms i'll come back to you but
question from me presumably though any
applicant or anyone can apply to have a
condition removed yeah that's correct so
yeah you can condition it
as much as you like
um yes
yeah um that's the same in the principle
yes you can the opposite of paul
explains about the concerns about how
that potentially could work in this
instance or the
the level of employment compared to
residential et cetera whether it would
really be a live work unit and the
ability to protect that goes hand in
hand with that in principle thank you
sorry mr smart i didn't mean to button
no that's fine yeah so
certainly for me so they've not changed
the floor plan at all
and
so theoretically there would be much
less car movements if they were living
there and working there
um
yeah actually i've not i've not really
got a problem with that i don't think
but i'll see i'll leave it i'll leave it
up to the um
the other members there but in fact we
can condition it i like because i think
we do need
we do need the workspaces
i'm sorry i'll come straight
sorry yeah see you chairman um
the only well highlight is obviously i
think from correct it's an office space
that this has been um retained as one of
a better phrase for the live work
obviously it's a very large space that
is apparently gonna be so
i think it would be reasonable to assume
if that space was to be effectively be
used there would need to be um
staff
to come and go so it would be there
would still be employees needing to come
and go to this site on top of the
occupier so yeah so there may be a list
but it would still be then the
residential coming and going on top of
the normal so it's a balancing exercise
more thanks it depends very much what
the work is doesn't it i mean my
experience with you know if you had a
chiropractor who lived there and a
visiting chiropractor you'd have two
patients coming and going every 15
minutes
but you might have an entirely different
business to have one client coming maybe
every day maybe not even every day and
that with no control of of outside the
others outside yeah were we told in the
application anywhere what the business
use was give us a rough idea because
that's already approved but
yes but within the class of use
it you know it is it is what it is
we've just got office i think
it's just office
but
yeah it just depends so i've got council
more than councillor stevens
thank you madam chairman um i was just
wondering though with
with the
the current climate i don't mean that i
mean the work
climates in your opinion is this the
sort of thing that's going to be
more prevalent because people are
working from home more
does that have sway on it or is that a
bit vague and things like that i was
your opinion
thank you chairman um
uh i won't
i don't like giving my opinion you know
i'd like to slip i like i like to give
professional advice not my opinion which
is a slightly different thing um
what my advice would be is i understand
what you're saying uh council and i
totally do and obviously this is
something that a lot of uh
people are putting forward to us and i i
think we all know that the world has
changed postcode
pandemic how that is though
we don't know government guidance has
not changed at the moment um
and
while there will still be you know
people working from this obviously an
office of that space i'm saying will
still attract
or to be able to be effectively used
would need to
have a number of staff so
um
i i almost think that'd be a moot point
and what i would then say is if you were
to move on to a very small area where
you say people are working from home you
know
i did that and still do that in my spare
bedroom and that's you know it wouldn't
be a that wouldn't level then there
wouldn't be a volume of employment land
that would be classed as live work
either so i think to a sense i can
understand your thought process but my
advice would be more that we should be
looking at making dwellings larger that
accommodate flexibility rather than
um
this sort of development in the rural
area thank you because obviously what i
would highlight is that the members
obviously are aware that the 2019
application was dismissed to appeal for
being in an unsustainable location and
we'd need to if obviously if there is a
movement against the officer's
recommendation members we need to
explain not just why they think this
site is acceptable but why it's
acceptable
in conflict with what the inspector said
um two years ago because in 2020 when it
was determined appeal was dismissed
thank you chairman if i may come back
when when
sorry
when it was a
question business were how many people
were working there or movements
i thought it was a question i thought
someone said it was a big i don't know
that it was see chairman yeah it was a
question story i don't think we know
anything about surgery
yeah
but who knows
i'm sorry i've got councillor stevenson
i'll come back
i'm not quite sure if this is matters
very much but really if so if this were
to be granted could somebody then use
the entire uh space for residential
given that you can go through the door
between the two anyway if you wanted
that huge room for something would you
just be able to use it entirely
residentially
see chairman um i said we can impose a
condition but we wouldn't be out there
policing it um and after 10 years if
that was done without permission they
would be able to get a little
development certificate
for it to be used solely as a dwelling
the reason the fact that we
one slash is difficult to proactively
enforce a condition is not a reason to
impose it
but
members should be conscious of the
ability to breach the conditions as well
so the effectiveness of the condition
but the fact that an enforcement
condition
could be breached isn't a reason to not
grant planning permission though thank
you chairman
councilman morgan you wanted to come
back
yes
with regards to that uh the um planning
inspectors refusal in june 2019 are you
in a position to give an opinion as to
whether there been any material changes
to the situation since that decision was
made
but your chairman the office report says
there hasn't been because that's what
the lpa's opinion is um
i know that we haven't got a five-year
land supply but that would be the only
position i would say would change but
look take him to count when inspector
says about it being unsustainable remote
from facilities i would consider that
that still all stands and would still be
a reason for refusal to be successful
appeal in the future otherwise we won't
be having the recommendation we have
thank you thank you
councillor
and thank you very much
wouldn't it be true that the position
has changed because it has commercial
use now whereas it was just
far more
or equestrian or whatever it was would
that not be a material oh that was a
massive material difference for your
chairman so i keep looking i can't see
money yeah um
i think there's two points in relation
to that council right um and while there
is maturation i would just say it was
known much for wait for two reasons one
as you can see that it hasn't been
implemented so while the fact that there
is the potential and fallback of this
office to be constructed it isn't there
in situ so and the
speed in which these applications have
come forward
uh brings into question the likelihood
of this
uh permission ever to be implemented and
the likelihood of the permission to be
implemented is a very large material
consideration in the uh weight that you
should give in a
full back position secondly the
council's policy supports conversion of
rural buildings to employment it
supports rural community etc our
policies do not support
conversion of agricultural buildings to
dwellings so
i would say that it is while it is
mature situation there's no demonstrable
weight because one of them is policy
compliant and is supported by our
policies one of them is not policy
compliant and is not supported by our
policies thank you chairman
because
you put me right if i'm wrong i mean
the fact that we don't have a five-year
housing land supply doesn't put anything
any nearer facilities than it already
was
um and actually it strikes me as a live
work unit
having such a large work unit attached
reduces the usefulness of the dwelling
because it's not everyone's coming this
is not back office but working at home
this is running a business
with other people coming and starting so
on
and no don't use that against me the
next application because
i mean planning what i want is you don't
put new dwellings in the countryside
council students
thank you chair could i please see where
would the garden be for the residential
part and can you see it from the road
and what would be the impact there thank
you
sorry i can't tell from that where the
garden is sorry but it's the green bit
outside
the hedge but inside the red line yeah
it looks like my reading of it looks
like it's between the barn and the out
building
sorry i'm being very stupid i don't
understand where the cotton is sorry
so the guard so the garden is um
it looks as though the garden is to the
right of the barn and in front of the
little outbuilding
and then it's behind he'll
it will be positioned behind hill barn
and the access will be between the hill
barn and hill place to get to the
property
it's not marked unfortunately so is it
sort of open plan is there a safety
issue there with people coming to and
from the work unit
um so there's
it's not believed to have any sort of
privacy in the immunity space
there's no sort of
fences i don't believe
see chairman the officer paul does talk
about it 5.7.2
and details haven't been provided in
relation to how it would be
[Music]
subdivided or taken off but there is a
space
i would say that
that proposed amenity space weighs
against the development it's not
particularly a successful
piece of amenity space
but taking into account how it wouldn't
be viewed unless people are accessing
the site i think on balance we've
considered as the potential fit to
deliver immunity space but i would agree
from your
query that i would guess your thoughts
are that it is not a particularly strong
and it wouldn't be a 100 policy
compliant level of immunity space
okay remember so is anybody moving
towards a
proposal
bearing in mind that you're going to
have your reasons at the ready
for going against
not only our previous decision but the
appeal inspectors
it's got to come as a job
well i think based upon what i've heard
in particular
we should be telling the previous
suspect's decision that i
moved to refuse
oh okay right so we're looking at the
officer's recommendation to refuse
proposed by council morgan council
filming was
the quickest to second thank you very
much
now having gone through the discussion
any other questions you know that you
wish to
this is where we get to the debate as
opposed to the discussion but as we're
going for the officer's recommendation i
would be might surprised if you didn't
have any but now's your shot
i don't know i'm still sitting on the
fence here with this one are we sure the
garden is not policy compliant but
unfortunately it's not that clear
certainly isn't clear to me so i mean
you know
officially chairman what i'd explain
obviously as of support this area here
would
be what would be the private immunity
space um
it hasn't been delineated how it would
be screened obviously we could impose a
condition but obviously it's going to be
separate from the main dwelling and any
screening wouldn't be particularly
attractive on the flip side due to it
potentially being used here it could it
wouldn't be as obviously viewed as would
normally be so
we've not put that in as a reason for
refusal but what we're saying is that i
would advise that it would weigh against
development because it isn't 100 plus
compliant as in it's not private in my
immunity space to the rear that would be
totally screened from
public vistas which obviously this isn't
but it's not formed a reason for refusal
so
um i think it's a bit of a moot point
actually that makes a difference to my
view because i thought at the end of the
discussion it said that it wasn't policy
compliant and i thought well the new
modern houses have got gardens that are
tiny and that that looks quite big
um
so that's completely changed my view on
the application in actual fact and and
if this application fails
i'd be in mind to make a um different
proposal um
and that was that was purely on the
garden was my problem with it and the
garden is now policy compliant and then
that's what we don't
know well i must be able to work it out
i mean how many how many sorry mr
chairman for clarity what we're saying
it's not about the space about whether
or not it's compliant we're talking
about whether it's to do with the
quality of it that means that it's not
100 policy compliant as in it will not
be
private in the traditional sense of a
screened area to the rear of the
property it will be an area to the front
of the property separated by the access
way which obviously we wouldn't normally
support but due to the relationship with
the rest of the street scene and the
long private drive access it's
considered that
the harm from this would not necessarily
be so significant as to form a reason
for refusal in its own sense so although
it's not traditionally policy compliant
in relation to size and quality we don't
think there's necessarily a reason for
refusal
on this
right in that case then that completely
changes my view because i thought that i
didn't make a country of proposals
because the last i heard was the garden
wasn't policy compliant and i was
looking the picture thinking
in a minute that must be policy
compliant it must be big enough so um i
i don't think i can make can i make a
separate an alternative proposal now do
we have to vote on the fact that we
haven't vote on the one we've got on the
table
however
you would be escorting your one two
three four and five year old children
there they're not gonna be popping in
and out the back door into their own
garden
however
that is
that's a point i just made we do have
the proposal um the officer
recommendation on the table so those in
favor of the officer recommendation to
refuse for all the reasons in the report
one two three four five
and those against
two
so that one is refused and i'm afraid
there's no while ago however we move on
to item six which is zero zero four four
three
and mr woods has said his piece um so if
we could have is the receptive separate
presentation isn't it sorry i've got
somebody else's keeping
thank you chairman
this application relates to the same
same site as the previous application
therefore i'll keep it brief the
application is for the conversion of an
existing
equestrian and storage building to one
dwelling and associate works within the
site
so location plan
this is the exist
what sidewall
exists in the proposed site plans
the existing floor plan
here's the proposed floor plan members
will note that this application has a
different internal layout the key
difference
are the provision of a fourth bedroom
and the removal of the flexible office
space
here are the existing proposed front and
side elevations
here are the existing
sorry existing and proposed rear and
side elevations
here's the existing outbuilding plans
here is the proposed app building plans
this is identical to the last
application
here are the site photos showing the
site access
photo showing the front elevation and
where the proposed vehicle parking would
be
photos showing side elevations
photos showing the out building and the
area facing the side elevation
photo showing the surround spots left
surrounding area
the end the proposed dwelling would not
be acceptable in principle as it would
be remote and disconnected from the
local services and facilities by reason
of its location and would lead to
domestication of the site which would
erode the character and beauty of the
countryside which has not been
adequately mitigated or justified as
such the application is therefore
recommended for refusal thank you
chairman thank you
right who's first council keys
right i live in a rural location
i've got enough screening around my
garden but if we can go back to them
pictures there's some fairly mature
hedges around there so
yeah
the buildings are altered
we go back to that's the buildings can
we go back to
what it looks
proposed to look like please because i
believe they're higher aren't they
the one before that
go back two pictures please
no
no forward
forward
forward
forward
forward
oh no backing sorry sorry wrong way
right yeah
i'll do that due to my age ago
so
that top left one
that grey bit on the top so it's going
to be slightly taller no yes
and an extension to the front isn't it
it's just a conversion just to give it
right so it's not made any higher at all
because oh look at that looks like is
it's a conversion for your chairman the
i think what's confusing
it's been shadowed out as though it
so it's the building will be exactly
it's the same building yeah so it's not
out up yet we're not adding anything to
it so right that's that's cleared my bed
up for that lobby
anybody else
nelson morgan
gosh
um
you're still planning 101 you don't put
new dwellings in the countryside
i know you've got it running in the
countryside yeah but the only way to
make all these
it it's lost an employment site which i
know it isn't in use but it could be
the previous one that doesn't work
he said that wasn't it was no use it was
dangerous and yet now we're saying it'd
be a lot for them
no it's not
i didn't quite say that
but that was the live work that was the
live work aspect that you've got a
family with potentially young children
chewing and friends
okay come on come back come back
counselor keys come back
chairman
there is nothing about loss of
employment in the reason for refusal so
don't
because that has never been implemented
so
any discussion about that would be
not was our advisor would not be a
mature today from terminus application
and i said like that as we discussed
earlier the full back position i think
should be given very limited way
like it was in the last one and even
less in this one due to the fact there
is no live work aspect to this this is
just new dwelling so i just advise that
okay i stand corrected lack of technical
knowledge
council morgan so sorry i just want to
return to my original point since we
refused the first application surely is
that it's not a material case for indeed
refusing this one
chairman my advice would be the
fuse of the last one weighs even further
against this application because
the only benefit that you might have
seen was i would devise between the two
was that one had some benefits in the
fact that it was a live work unit
there is those benefits are silent on
this application so
i'd be very confused that how members
could come to a different conclusion and
your reason for approval would have to
explain that difference between the last
application and this one and
i can't it's my first advice is i
couldn't see any way that there could be
a different conclusion thank you
chairman
so if i might come back
which is what i raised earlier the
reason i approved the first application
was because it was um employment and we
need employment so that was why i was so
very interested in getting approved i
was sitting on the fence for the last
one i was happy they'd kept the
commercial
but the biggest problem was that there
wasn't a private safe garden for the
residential
area that was joined onto the commercial
so theoretically if it would have come
back with a a better garden we wouldn't
have had the problems with live work and
we would have kept the
commercial unit so it it might be if it
came back i can't say that but if there
was changes to it it would be more
acceptable and still keep the commercial
area
through your chairman can i just say two
things one
the reason fusion had nothing to do with
immunity space which members just
refused so any changes that would not be
a material situation for any future
application secondly
that was that application has been
determined so two things one
any considerations that about positive
or how that could be changed shouldn't
form part of the consideration of this
application
um
and secondly i've forgotten the point i
was going to make so i apologize and if
it comes back to me
no no no that that was me going off
pieces i'm sorry i was corrected by a
professional advisor and i stand
corrected i was wrong
i'm trying to remember counseling since
i'm staring at you i remember what she
said
no i'll repeat it again basically it
appeared that the
[Music]
the
employment area had no real benefit on
the last one and also it was a negative
for the residential conversion path and
residential because the parking and the
access in the garden which i accept
um and because i thought it was not
policy compliant and i thought that's
ridiculous not to be policy compliant
and if we come to this one
and this hasn't got any
um
commercial and we're saying well it's
got no commercial now so it's definitely
not so i i you know i think maybe the
first application perhaps could have
been done better
yeah thank you chairman it has come back
to me thank you council it's helpful um
what i was going to say is obviously
opinion whether it's yourselves as
members whether it's mine etc is a moot
point we have to determine plan
application according to the development
plan unless material considerations
indicate otherwise
and
the decision that the committee has just
made is a material consideration
so that should affect everybody's
thoughts on the termination of this
application irrespective of how they
felt or thought about the last
application because and that's why if
members had approved the last
application i would have had to have
done a verbal update about how that in
my professional opinion would have
affected this application thank you
chairman thank you um
actually senators you might be able to
help i'm looking for the inspector's
reason for refusal last time
well that depends on what he said if he
says it's remote from facilities there's
sustainability i haven't gone anywhere
chairman um
the inspector to be honest deals with it
in a number of paragraphs so it's not
particularly uh
succinct to uh give you a guidance but
um what paragraph 10 says accordingly
the appeal
or she's in the appeal decision
yes so accordingly the appeal
development does not constitute a
suitable location for the provision of
dwellings as the proposal would fail to
comply with enlist our policies uh which
seeks amongst other things liver homes
in the most sustainable locations um and
obviously it talks about higher up about
poor street food lighting and all
matters such as that um
so i think that stands on all four legs
with this and it does with the last um
application as well so um very difficult
i think my advice but yeah thank you
chairman all right i've got council keys
and council fleming
right thank you sean
this is agricultural still
this piece of land that i was talking
about question still agriculture barns
so this house
if it doesn't come the applicant could
put in for monstrous grain stores
that don't go through planning
application they get i can't remember
the name of it and you could have
lorries in here 24 hours a day seven
days a week
in the countryside yet we don't oops we
don't want one house
the chairman correct am i correct for
that
for your chairman what i would say is
this isn't the thing about this
application is that
the rural countryside has agricultural
uses and that is one of the biggest
employers of economy in the country
that is what
is accepted in the countryside because
it is the countryside
what isn't accepted in the countryside
according to our policies and
government's advice
is housing so they are totally two
separate mute it's like arguing that you
should convert every piece of employment
land to housing because you have
vehicles and we'll only have dwellings
we'll have no employment we'll have no
agriculture we'll have nothing that is
not what government advice is and it is
a flawed argument in planning terms i'd
advise your counselor please thank you
chairman
as members know from the training worst
case scenario the positives or negatives
should not be a material consideration
in termination application you should
determine applications in front of you
not on what if could happen at extremes
we do not have an application for
agriculture workers dwelling taking into
account the area edged red i'd be very
surprised if we would accept one in that
small area but my advice would be for
members to determine this application
for a single dwelling not it would not
giving any weight to the idea that
potentially one day could be an
agricultural worker
the area in blue is that owned by the
applicant as well
so it's all owned so
there is another access down the bottom
i just wanted to thank you chairman to
return to what mr lee was saying earlier
so our our decision we've just made on
the previous application is material now
good thank you
so anybody got a proposal
thank you manager
the circumstances based on the previous
application that we
follow the uh office's recommendations
and refused
seconded saw council fleming's hand
first absolutely
and he asked okay we have a proposal on
the table
any further debate i think we've
probably done it but now's the moment if
you have anything to say
okay
could i have a show of hands please for
those of you i don't know i i don't i
don't think it's been overly helpful
that we've had the two applications
hasn't been particularly helpful
it's been a bit confusing hasn't it so
yes um
vhm and firstly obviously it's the
applicant's gift to submit them at the
same time but actually the applicant did
request that they actually were
debated at the same meeting but as i
would say i i hope it while it may have
had some confusion hopefully it hasn't
been too difficult because each
application has been i would say
relatively fairly balanced and debated
in on its own merits without it being
cross-pollinated or anything thank you
thank you
okay can we have a show of hands please
for the office of recommendation to
refuse for all the reasons given in the
report
one two three four five six thank you
councillor white against
okay so um
members um
of the public that application too is
refused in line with the officer's
recommendation
item
seven and last is any items the business
the chairman decides are urgent you'll
all be grateful to hear there are none
so members and officers and members of
the public with thanks for all your
contributions this evening i draw the
meeting to a close at 8 22. thank you
everyone